next on the t-15 time major championship
winner competing in the match for a
third time the goat Tiger Woods
[Applause]
hey Sam
roll right there
where's that at
that's my partner girl
[Applause]
and the Mystery Club of Tiger Woods
tiger you can just you can just tell us
yeah be it well I'm just going to kind
of shape one here
okay you're not cheating on us here
tiger is one of the other guys watch out
camera I wanted to watch this live my
whole life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
they took all the clubs so I got no
choice but to chase one Chase one and
kind of get it down there and I think I
chasing off the teeth I got a chance to
chase one up there you know use the
slope to kind of Dewey might skip up
there a little bit well you being
serious if you just screwing around with
us no I'm being serious um unfortunately
my game plan is kind of backfired as a
tree right here in my line here I was
gonna
hey In fairness to you it's dark you
didn't see the tree no but I think I can
actually it's only 207 to the front edge
did I did made me say sure that bunker
there
did yeah good left of the green tea yep
go no all right nice read
that looks good that looks really good
[Applause]
all right good shot tiger good shot
what's up some pretty chances coming up
here
try
swing
the yard
oh that could be good huh stay there
yeah it stayed up on the proper Shelf
you have a good run out of tiger
forgot to tell you guys tiger gets a
stroke here so
I'm glad I didn't say it hard to beat a
32. yeah no kidding eh
yeah
oh my god when it crossed the hole wow
it's a big
but you had it
shout out tiger
same number 177 on the ball speed and
you guys got some speed ranks Fairway
good shot
all future sponsors of the match
[Applause]
it could be the uh it could be the match
eight Chuck versus a uh cheese fries a
cheeseburger
[Music]
that's it
sit oh my God oh my God
come on come on
yeah stay right there good shot
[Applause]
tiger
I get shot dude
that could be closest
oh my goodness I had no business missing
good try I didn't think it was going to
miss low that's for sure
76.
[Applause]
beautiful purple Fairway
s
good stuff partner partner sorry no
all done loved it uh second place in bad
guys
[Laughter]